يعني اقل من ساعه هنا لكي يعني يصل منتصف
الليل هناك تجمعات يعني خلفي امام بوابه
هذه البوابه التاريخيه الشهيره التي عاده
يعني تشهد الاحتفالات راس السنه احتفالات
كبيره جدا هذا العام عاد الاحتفال الى
البوابه بعد عامين من القطاع بسبب كورونا
ووقف كامل الاحتفالات والالعاب الناريه
ولكن رغم عودته هذا العام فهو احتفال
مقتضب لانه كانت هناك توقعات من السلطات
الصحيه في المانيا بانه الخريف سيحمل معه
ربما ما هو جديد من قرانا لذلك كانت ترخيص
الذي حصل عليه منظم الاحتفال هنا لاعداد
محدوده من المحترفين 2050 شخص فقط سمح لهم
بالدخول همم يعني بعد الحصول على بطاقات
مصطفى هنا ولكن مجانيه همم ولذلك يعني رغم
انه ليس هناك كجمعات كبيره حولي ولكن في
شوارع اخرى في المانيا هناك بالفعل تجمعات
لاشخاص تكون المفرقعات الناريه منذ يعني
وقت مبكر من اليوم وحتى منذ يوم امس لانه
يعني برلين معروفه بانه هي ربما يعني
واحده من اكثر المدن التي يطلق فيها
المواطنون الالعاب الناريه في عيد راس
السنه كان هناك منع للالعاب الناريه هنا
في محيط هذه المنطقه وفي بعض المناطق
الاخرى في برلين العاب الناريه المرتفعه
التي تسبب بالكثير من التلوث وهذا سببه
يعني لتخفيف من تلوث سريع الالعاب الناريه
في المناطق التي تعتبر اشد الاقتصادا همم
بالسكان وايضا يعني في المناطق القريبه من
المستشفيات ومناطق اخرى حددتها هذه
الحكومه تتعلمين بان حزب الخضر يعني هو
ينتمي لهذه الحكومه لذلك هذه الاسباب يعني
او يعني الاهتمامات البيئيه في خلفيه يعني
هذه القرارات ولكن بالفعل ترقب كبير لدى
الالمان وداع العام 2022 ااا الذي يعني
كان صعبا بالنسبه اليهم شهيدا يعني تضخم
كبير ارتفاع اسعار الغاز والكهرباء وامل
على ان يحمل الالعاب المقبل همم غلا اقل
وتضخم اقل ايضا هل اثرت قلت تلك العوامل
على المظهر الاحتفاليه هذا العام بدايك
يعني هنا في البوابه كما ذكرت لانه الحشود
اصلا يعني كان همم
مسيطر عليها كانت محدوده من وقت سابق ولكن
هناك احتفالات كبيره في الشوارع يعني في
شوارع بنين الكثير من الاشخاص نزلوا
الشوارع الاحتفال بالاسلحه او بالالعاب
الناريه التي كانت ممنوعه طوال العاملين
السابقين لذلك الاحتفالات يمكن القول
بانها عاده الاحتفالات يعني غير المنظمه
عادت بشكل السابق لما كانت عليه يعني قبل
همم
الاجراءات التي بسبب وباءنا وهنا يعني
يعمل المنظمون بان يكون العمل ايضا من دون
ايت يعني اجراءات تمنع حشود اكبر بكثير من
التي شهدتها هناك بعض الفرق الغنائيه التي
يعني كانت على هذا المنبر منذ يعني ساعات
المساء ايضا من المتوقع ان تاتي بعد فرقه
الشهيره التي ستغني ربما قبل منتصف نعم
منتصف الليل بقليل عندما يعني ستختتم هذا
سيختتم هذا الحفل نعم شكرا لك راغده من
برلين شكرا لك على كل تلك المعلومات
وننتقل الان الى مراسلتنا عروب عبد الحق
من لندن تنضم الينا لتخبرنا عن الاجواء
الاحتفاليه هناك عن اثر الاشخاص مقارنه
بالاعوام السابقه
يعني اقل من ساعتين على استقبال بريطانيا
للعام الجديد وتودع عام 2022 ربما بيفرحها
بسبب قساوه هذا العام على العديد من
البريطانيين نحن الان موجود
في وسط لندن وهي احدى المنطقتين يعني التي
من
العاده بانتج العديد من همم السكان
والمقيمين وحتى الزائرين الى بريطانيا
طبعا هناك مناطق مدفوعه الاجر مثل المناطق
القريبه من لندن
ستتم هناك الالعاب الناريه عروض الالعاب
الناريه وهذه المنطقه التي هي يعني مجانيه
لكل الناس وبالتالي همم
يجذب هذه المنطقه عاده الكثير من الناس
كما سمعنا تصريحات لعمده لندن قال بان همم
هناك ثلاث مفاجات الليله همم ااا لذلك
ننتظر لنرى ما هذه المفاجات الثلاثه التي
تكلم عنها عوده لندن وقال بان عروض
الالعاب الناريه التي ستكون او ستعرض
الليله ستكون من الافضل في اوروبا هذا
العام طبعا لانها تاتي بخلاف العامين
الماضيين اللذين لم يشهدا يعني اي العاب
ناريه بسبب القيود التي كانت مفروضه على
التجمعات الناس بسبب بسبب كرونه وبالتالي
ننتظر ما هي هذه المفاجاه طبعا نعم
بيعها في همم المناطق المخصصه لمشاهده
لعروض الالعاب الناريه هذه جيلان ومن
المتوقع ان تجذب العاصمه لندن حوالي
400,000 او همم نصف مليون من الاشخاص اا
يتجمعون في المناطق المخصصه لمشاهده
الالعاب الناريه والمناطق ايضا الاخرى
والميادين الرئيسيه في لندن مثل هذه
المنطقه بالاضافه الى سكوير والسرور ومع
للاضطرابات خاصه في قطاع النقل هل اثر ذلك
على الاحتفالات وعلى تنقل الاشخاص في هذه
الليله
يعني طبعا جيلان تاتي هذه الاحتفالات تحت
اجواء ربما او يعني خلف هذه الاجواء
الاحتفاليه يوجد هناك اجواء ليست سعيده
جدا هنا في بريطانيا خاصه للاشخاص الذين
يعيشون في المناطق البعيده همم قليلا عن
وسط لونه كما نعلم هذه المنطقه سياحيه
بامتياز ولكن عاصمه البريطانيه همم يعني
عاصمه كبيره فيها العديد من الاحياء التي
تعتمد عاده على دائره السكان المحليين او
على على المقيمين في تلك المناطق وبالتالي
تعتمد على همم العائدات القادمه من همم من
هذه يعني من منها او لا وبالتالي هناك
العديد من الاشخاص الذين فضلوا الاحتفال
بليله راس السنه في منازلهم بسبب الازمه
الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها بريطانيا كان
قطاع الضيافه همم في بريطانيا قال وكشف عن
بعض الارقام قال بان الخسائر التي تكبدها
قطاع هو 1.5 مليون جنيه استرليني وبالتالي
هي يعني هي مبالغ كبيره وذلك بسبب
الالغاءات التي حصلت في همم المطاعم او في
الجهات الترفيهيه اما بسبب غلاء الازمه
المعيشيه وعدم رغبه الناس في صرف الاموال
ولكن هناك ايضا الاضرابات المتكرره التي
تضرب او التي تشهدها قطاعات مختلفه في
لندن سواء قطاع الصحه او قطاع الاسعاف
وحتى القطاع السكك الحديديه الذي ربما هو
الاكثر تاثيرا على احتفالات راس السنه هذه
هذا العام لانه كما نعلم يعني يعتمد
البريطانيون بشكل كبير على قطاع النقل
العام في التنقل من مكان الى اخر وبالتالي
هم متخوفون من همم الخروج ربما من منازلهم
اذا كانوا يعيشون في مناطق بعيده همم
قليلا عن وسط لندن وذلك بسبب عدم يعني
معرفه او التاكد من همم اوقات هذه همم
الرحلات الى الى منازلهم